prime de science sociale dans lequel on
va lire un article de sciences sociales
tout ça déjà pour actualiser nos
connaissances par rapport à ce qui se
produit dans le l'univers de la
recherche des sciences sociales mais
aussi sur cette chaîne pour vous donner
des clés et des bases de lecture
d'article de sciences sociales pour vous
qui apprenez ou qui enseignait les
sciences sociales alors moi je suis
professeur dans le secondaire et donc
c'est vraiment à ce titre que je stream
ici je suis pas du tout un spécialiste
des questions qui seront abordées mais
j'ai essayé d'enseigner à mes élèves et
à tous ceux et celles qui sont derrière
leur écran ce que sont et comment
fait-on des sciences sociales alors
aujourd'hui l'article qui a été choisi
c'est un article que j'apprécie beaucoup
par sa thématique qui est assez
originale on va s'intéresser à ce qui se
passe dans un petit village français et
dans ce petit village en fait il y a des
luttes de pouvoir des luttes d'influence
qui se mettent en place pour des choses
qui peuvent apparaître anecdotiques et
banales
comme une fête de village l'organisation
d'une fête de village mais en fait
derrière ça il y a toute une volonté de
maîtriser et de
participer aussi à la prise de décision
politique dans ce village là donc c'est
très intéressant personnellement je vis
dans aussi dans un village périurbain
qui n'est pas en France mais qui est en
Belgique et c'est des choses que j'ai
déjà pu observer simplement autour de
moi donc je trouve que l'article est
très intéressant et aussi au niveau
méthodologique il y a des choses qui
sont très bien construites au début de
l'article alors il s'agit d'un article
de Quentin schnappeur que vous
retrouverez
en description de la vidéo alors vous ne
retrouverez pas quand un schnappeur mais
vous retrouverez les références qui vous
permettront de trouver cet article si
qui est à disposition sur la plateforme
cairn alors la plateforme Karm c'est une
grande plateforme qui rassemble tout un
ensemble de publications scientifiques
et donc
sur cette plateforme vous allez
retrouver beaucoup de recherches
actuelles qui se font et qui ont été
publiés dans des revues à comité de
lecture alors la revue aujourd'hui c'est
la revue politique qui est des revues je
suis depuis très très longtemps puisque
quand j'étais étudiant je me souviens
déjà avoir lu des articles de cette
revue le seul petit souci j'ai envie de
dire c'est que les articles les plus
récents sont payants
les articles qui datent de plus de trois
ans sont à disposition gratuite donc
merci Kern et merci aux maisons
d'édition qui propose cette gratuité
mais si vous êtes étudiant ou enseignant
dans
une institution universitaire alors pas
dans un dans un collège dans un lycée ou
dans une école secondaire en Belgique ça
vous n'aurez vous n'y aurait pas accès
mais si vous êtes étudiant dans une
faculté vous aurez accès à ces
ressources parce que normalement voilà
vous avez des codes pour y arriver et
pour vous authentifier avec votre compte
de votre université donc voilà je ne
vais pas non plus diffuser l'article
puisque l'article ben voilà est soumis à
des droits et donc ça serait un petit
peu malaisé pour moi de vous projeter
l'article donc je veux en lire certains
passages alors l'article s'appelle donc
une fête à soi puisque je vous l'ai dit
on va vraiment prendre le cas d'une
organisation festive
pour essayer de voir justement quelles
sont les différentes luttes d'influence
qui se mettent en place migration
résidentielle lutte de pouvoir est
recomposition des sociabilités
politiques dans un bourg pérenurbain
alors on va pas se cacher souvent les
chercheuses les chercheurs de sciences
sociales ils utilisent des mots et des
titres assez compliqués dans leur
article mais en fait tout ce qui est mis
ici est très très simple migration
résidentielle on a dans les campagnes et
dans les campagnes françaises des rétro
migrations suite à l'exode rural à
partir du 19e siècle et peut-être même
un petit peu avant on a plein de
populations qui vont quitter les
campagnes pour rejoindre les centres
urbains et aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle
et bien il y a des rétro migrations les
gens retournent dans les campagnes pour
plusieurs raisons en tout cas si pas
directement dans les campagnes dans les
espaces périurbains donc on verra plus
tard je vais parier ici ce qu'un espace
périurbain si vous ne le savez pas je
le définirais au cours de l'article plus
tard et merci à Julie pour les
encouragements c'est super sympa donc
migration résidentielle c'est ça on a
finalement la démographie d'un village
qui va être bouleversé par l'arrivée ou
le retour de population qui avait quitté
ces espaces qui étaient absent de ces
espaces lutte de pouvoir je vous l'ai
dit de quoi il s'agissait et
recomposition des sociabilités qui
parlent avec qui qui fait des alliances
politiques avec qui c'est tout ça qui va
être abordé dans cet article alors
l'auteur quand un Snapper directement
commence avec une définition de ce
qu'est la périurbanisation depuis la fin
des années 1960 les villes connaissent
un mouvement de déconcentration de leurs
activités économiques et de leur
fonction résidentielle en poursuivant
leur développement dans la campagne dans
les campagnes environnantes c'est-à-dire
que le tissu urbain est en lui-même
saturé en bâti et bien on va exporter
les les magasins on va exporter les
habitations
juste dans les couronnes qui sont à
proximité des villes tout ça est bien
sûr permis par l'avènement de la voiture
individuelle qui va permettre aux
personnes de pouvoir voyager plus
facilement et finalement de négliger la
distance les distances finalement ne
comptent plus puisque l'automobile nous
permet de nous déplacer donc ça c'est
tout un contexte qui a lieu dans les
années 60 et qui continue évidemment
jusqu'à aujourd'hui en poursuivant leur
développement dans les campagnes
environnantes la périurbanisation se
traduite par une polarisation croissante
de ces espaces ruraux et par l'arrivée
de population en quête d'accession à la
propriété
issue des agglomérations centrales comme
des villages les plus reculés
voilà on souhaite aller vivre à la
campagne parce que le cadre de vie est
plus agréable aussi parce que parfois
plus à l'extérieur des villes c'est
aussi moins cher le foncier est moins
cher et donc c'est intéressant aussi
alors quels sont les effets de la
périurbanisation
on continue ici ni territoire de
relégation ni univers pour les classes
moyennes les couronnes périurbaines
présentent une forte hétérogénéité
sociale c'est-à-dire qu'on va retrouver
plein de classes sociales différentes
plein de personnes qui viennent de
milieu différents ou d'origine
différente et spatial selon l'histoire
elle est spécificités des communes les
caractéristiques des unités urbaines
voisines et les distances à celle-ci
évidemment on pourrait pas dire que
l'espace périurbain c'est exactement ça
comme chose parce que tout va dépendre
un petit peu de ton tissu dans le Nord
Pas de Calais où il y a eu des
charbonnages tu n'auras pas les mêmes
dynamiques que en Haute-Savoie par
exemple
proche de la composition sociale moyenne
des mondes ruraux les communes les plus
éloignées des villes accueillent
davantage de ménage populaire donc plus
on va s'éloigner du centre urbain plus
on aura des personnes issues des milieux
les plus populaires des petits
agriculteurs des petits artisans des
ouvriers des employés vont être vraiment
repoussés parfois très loin des villes
parfois évincé par le prix par les prix
immobiliers tandis que les villages
situés à proximité immédiate des grandes
métropoles concentrent les cadres
supérieurs le cadre supérieur c'est
quelqu'un qui aura des fonctions de
management qui va encadrer une équipe
dans une entreprise ou dans une
administration cadre supérieur et bien
c'est voilà par exemple le directeur du
marketing le directeur financier là on
est vraiment sur les cadres qui
encadrent les cadres moyens
la morphologie différenciée de ces
territoires donc leur apparence les
rapports de force entre les groupes
sociaux à l'échelle locale se reflètent
dans les propriétés sociales des
populations qui investissent les
associations et les conseils municipaux
donc on voit que les associations
locales le club de foot ou une petite
une petite asbl je ne sais pas comment
on dit en français en pour la France
donc asbl c'est association sans but
lucratif
mais aussi les conseils municipaux donc
les conseils communaux vont être
investis de ces nouvelles populations
dans les espaces les plus industrialisés
ce sont plutôt des classes populaires
stabilisées et des salariés
intermédiaires de l'industrie
relativement proche socialement qui
s'engage sur les scènes locales et donc
dans ces milieux là on voit que c'est un
autre public qui va investir les
organismes et les institutions locales
et on parle de classe populaire
stabilité on en parle beaucoup dans nos
différentes vidéos puisque les classes
populaires c'est ceux qui vraiment ont
pas beaucoup de moyens mais ne sont pas
non plus proches de la précarité et de
se retrouver en grande difficulté quoi
c'est à dire qu'ils doivent faire très
attention mais leur situation n'est pas
non plus totalement précaire
à l'extrême nuitée inverse
l'embourgeoisement des territoires
périurbains se manifestent par des
logiques d'entre-soi et de clôture
résidentielle à travers des politiques
de limitation des construction et
sauvegardes des espaces naturels donc
parfois vous voyez que les politiques
publiques comme le fait de préserver
certains espaces naturels vont être en
fait très préjudiciables pour une
démocratisation de cet espace là quand
je dis démocratisation c'est que tout le
monde puisse venir y vivre parce que si
on réduit l'offre forcément les prix
augmentent et donc ça va
favoriser un embourgeoisement que
seulement les classes bourgeoises
viennent sur ces espaces-là et donc
phénomène de ghetto mais de ghetto de
riches dans ce cas-ci c'est ce qu'on
appelle ici la logique d'entre-soi et de
clôture résidentielle alors ce qui est
intéressant dans un article scientifique
c'est que par exemple ici l'auteur
logique d'entre-soi est suivie d'un
petit chiffre en exposant un petit 7 et
clôture résidentielle donc ça renvoie
des notes infrapage Inal qui elle
renvoie vers d'autres articles donc en
fait si aujourd'hui je fais ma recherche
et je me rends compte que c'est logique
d'entre soi sont plus intéressantes pour
ma recherche à moi que l'article que je
suis occupé de lire et bien je vais
finalement peut-être abandonner
l'article que je suis occupé de lire
pour aller voir cet article qui parle
plus profondément des logiques d'entre
soi et là en l'occurrence par exemple ça
serait un article de F de sage je sais
pas si c'est
le genre de la personne un peuplement de
qualité mise en oeuvre de la loi SRU
dans le périurbain résidentiel aisé et
discrimination discrète dans la revue
gouverne et action publique
voilà donc ça c'est aussi important
quand vous lisez un article c'est de ne
pas négliger les notes impratinal si
vous voyez des concepts ou des notions
ou des affirmations qui peuvent être
plus pertinentes pour vos recherches à
vous ou vos centres d'intérêt si vous le
faites en freestyle
tout l'enjeu pour ces catégories
supérieures consistent à préserver
l'agrément rural et villageois de leur
commune que l'étalement urbain et la
croissance démographique démographique
sont susceptibles de remettre en cause
donc ces populations aisées qui quittent
les villes viennent à la campagne mais
on vit de garder les caractéristiques de
la campagne ce qui est un peu paradoxal
parce que justement leur arrivée des
natures ce qui était l'espace périurbain
avant avant ces phénomènes
démographiques
alors on voit directement ici
[Musique]
la mise en place d'une problématique les
bonnes recherches sont celles qui ont
des problématiques puissantes et souvent
quand on débute en sciences sociales et
qu'on veut problématiser c'est pour le
coup problématique aussi alors
problématique c'est pas forcément un
problème à résoudre un résoudre les
sciences sociales n'ont pas vocation
a toujours trouvé des réponses et des
solutions à d'éventuelles problèmes
quand on parle de problématique il
s'agit plutôt d'un problème théorique ou
d'un paradoxe qui est particulièrement
intéressant à étudier ici la
problématique que j'avais identifié
alors on vous dit jamais voilà si la
problématique de l'article enfin jamais
parfois ça arrive que ça soit beaucoup
plus évident ici c'est pas évident c'est
moi qui lis l'article de cette manière
là donc la problématique serait d'un
côté le fait qu'on ait une hétérogénéité
sociale donc on va avoir un public très
diversifié au niveau sociologique
et de l'autre on a le conflit politique
et d'usage du territoire qui est lié à
cette est originalité donc c'est ça
la problématique de cet article c'est le
fait que le tissu rural va se
diversifier et du coup ben il y a des
confrontations symboliques ou réel qui
peuvent se mettre en place par réel
n'est pas forcément le bon mot mais je
veux dire des confrontations c'est pas
forcément on arrivait aux mains quoi ça
peut être des conflits qui sont beaucoup
plus larvés donc je trouve ici l'article
très intéressant parce que en une page
l'auteur nous présente vraiment l'objet
et c'est une très belle synthèse qui est
réalisée c'est pas toujours évident dans
un article de d'avoir cet esprit
synthétique parfois il y a certaines
recherches qui ont qui ont du mal un peu
à accoucher de leurs problématique mais
ici c'est très bien fixé dès le départ
alors on continue avec quelques éléments
qui nous sont proposés notamment une
enquête qui avait été réalisée par
Catherine bidou dans les années 70 des
années 70 ou on souligné que les
nouvelles classes moyennes et
supérieures
arrivaient justement dans ces espaces
avec un certain idéal villageois
et donc elle mettait déjà en évidence
dans ces années-là dans ces années là
l'envie pour ces aventuriers du
quotidien entre guillemets d'investir
des comités de fête ou
des associations comme celle là et qu'il
y avait déjà à l'époque des caractères
très conflictuels dans ces
manifestations ou dans ses organisations
et donc ici on est vraiment dans le
prolongement de ces articles et là
l'auteur nous propose son objet d'étude
et pour lui il va travailler sur les
processus d'appropriation des espaces
ruraux périurbains par les classes
moyennes supérieures les classes
moyennes et les classes supérieures et
ce processus d'appropriation repose sur
un encadrement des sociabilités festives
donc pour reformuler tout ça on a ces
classes favorisées qui arrivent sur des
espaces anciennement ruraux qui sont
aujourd'hui des espaces périurbains ils
vont vouloir s'investir s'approprier le
territoire et ça se fait par la
sociabilité qu'on peut avoir lors de
fête et de festivités
et tout ça étant parallèle et mis en
parallèle avec la conquête du pouvoir
communal parce que dans les petites
communes bien souvent les personnes qui
sont très en vue dans les comités des
fêtes ou dans les fêtes de village mais
finalement c'est elle qui vont aussi
pouvoir être élu lors des élections
parce que simplement les gens les
connaissent et qu'il y a un régime de
proximité qui marche super bien à
l'échelle d'un bout ou d'un village et
donc ici on nous propose la question de
départ qui est comment comprendre les
engagements de cadre et de profession
intermédiaire proche du secteur public
parce qu'on se rend compte que c'est une
certaine partie
des classes supérieures qui sont ici en
jeu dans des fêtes de village aussi
constestée et culturellement peu
légitime parce que c'est ça aussi qui
est intéressant et là il y a une sorte
de tension
et je dis souvent aux élèves
si vous avez le choix entre plusieurs
problématiques choisissez celle dans
laquelle vous sentez qu'il y a une
tension les grandes tensions c'est par
exemple des tensions entre liberté
sécurité vous voyez ce genre de choses
qui sont qui sont qui mettent en
opposition les comportements des
individus et ici la tension en fait
c'est que tu as des classes qui vont
être fortement dotées en capitaux
culturels qui ont des diplômes qui ont
des fonctions très valorisantes et
valorisées socialement et pourtant elles
vont aller tu vois dans les fêtes de
village où c'est cochons à la broche et
des choses comme ça quoi et donc c'est
un peu paradoxal parce que on s'attend
pas à ce qu'elles aillent vers ce type
de manifestation ces manifestations sont
peu légitimes et quand on dit quelque
chose de légitime qu'est-ce qui est
légitime bon ben là il y a toute une
histoire de la sociologie à reprendre
depuis Bourdieu où il y a des contenus
qui sont plus légitimes que d'autres
même si tout évolue toujours
et donc on nous rappelle que les fêtes
de village c'est vraiment la sociabilité
comment se faire des amis dans un milieu
rural ou dans un espace anciennement
rural comme ici ça va être les fêtes de
village qui vont permettre justement de
tisser des liens de rencontrer des gens
et de se créer un réseau de relations et
historiquement mais plutôt c'était
plutôt des agriculteurs qui étaient dans
ces fêtes de village les fêtes de
village était des fêtes d'agriculteurs
et donc ces institutions sont
étroitement liées au pouvoir municipal à
lisière du champ politique comme je le
disais les comités des fêtes constituent
en effet des lieux de définition et de
mise en scène de l'image sociale du
territoire et représente la première
filière d'accès aux mandat municipal
pour les mers ruraux donc voilà les
agriculteurs finalement trust et les
sièges dans les conseils municipaux mais
de toute façon la majorité des gens une
grande partie des gens dans un village
avait une activité agricole même si
certains parfois avaient une autre
activité complémentaire à côté mais tout
le monde mettait à lapin à la pâte la
main à la pâte de la de l'agriculture
dans certains territoires pur
urbains leur reprise en main s'articule
à la contestation de la domination des
agriculteurs sur les conseils municipaux
et accentue la marginalisation de ce
groupe social à l'échelle à l'échelon
communale et donc il y a vraiment un
refoulement des agriculteurs de la vie
du village mais tout d'abord parce que
c'est un public vieillissant il y a de
moins en moins d'agriculteurs
et en plus voilà il y a une action un
peu de combat de lutte pour qui détient
le pouvoir à l'échelle du village qui se
fait entre les nouveaux arrivants et la
population historique qui était
essentiellement composée d'agriculteurs
ici le village voilà le nom qui est
mentionné ici c'est le village de
plibout dans l'ouest de la France donc
c'est 4000 habitants on est à une
dizaine de kilomètres d'Aubigné qui est
une ville moyenne en bourgeoisie
et donc démographiquement comme on le
disait c'est corroboré par les
statistiques on voit de plus en plus une
population se diversifier mais avec
certaines caractéristiques qui vont nous
être précisées ici
il y a bien sûr des recompositions du
public mais il reste des activités
industrielles dans les environs ou au
village comme par exemple deux usines
d'équarrissage et de fabrication de
camping-cars donc le bout se distingue
ainsi des villages en bourgeoisés des
périphéries polyènes parce qu'on garde à
plibou un public aussi ouvrier et on va
voir les jeux d'alliance qui vont se
mettre en place au sein du village
alors ce que j'ai noté ici c'est qu'en
fait l'auteur nous explique l'intérêt de
s'intéresser à plibou
on ne sera pas sur une observation qui
sera représentative parce que plus n'est
pas représentatif de l'ensemble des
villages périurbains où il y a de
l'embourgeoisement mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est
caractéristiques parce que plus beau a
des caractéristiques c'est le fait de
conserver cette population ouvrière et
c'est ça qui rend l'observation
intéressante donc en sciences sociales
on est bien sûr pas sur on est bien sûr
pas sur des modèles de reproductibilité
comme on le serait dans les sciences
naturelles et c'est le fait de
multiplier parfois les contextes
d'observation de multiplier les
observations
qui qui sont proposés alors bonjour
Google
non c'est pas précisé mais le terme en
bourgeoisé c'est surtout moi qui
l'utilise même s'il est mentionnaire
comme je l'ai dit ici dans la phrase que
je viens de lire mais on ne qualifie pas
l'embourgeoisement alors après je n'ai
pas été attentif à ça est-ce que
l'auteur nous renvoie vers un autre
article qui redéfinirait
l'embourgeoisement mais ici en
bourgeoisement est plutôt pris du côté
de d'avoir simplement des CSP plus comme
on le dirait qui viennent dans le
village CP+ catégorie
socioprofessionnelle supérieure et donc
les cadres supérieurs c'est typiquement
le public qu'on considère comme un
public bourgeois
mais le problème de du mot bourgeois
c'est il est un peu connoté suite
à toutes les publications marxiste qui
peuvent exister donc voilà
mais c'est pas un mot qui est très
utilisé dans l'article il est juste
utilisé ici je pense et quelques fois
ailleurs pendant plus de 10 ans le
comité d'organisation de la Foire
d'Automne donc ce qu'on appelle le COFA
et je reviendrai plusieurs fois sur ce
terme COFA puisque c'est vraiment le
comité des fêtes finalement de cette
fois
qui est la principale manifestation
festive de plibou
et on va voir comment ça va se passer
dans le COFA c'est vraiment un
feuilleton et c'est ça que j'aime
beaucoup dans les sciences sociales
c'est que parfois tu as pas besoin de
lire une fiction pour savoir tout un
univers qui est décrit la réalité et
dépasse parfois et souvent la fiction
ici il y a vraiment des jeux de pouvoir
et donc depuis les années 80 et la
relance de la foire de l'Union des
commerçants et le syndicat local des
exploitants les agriculteurs étaient au
cœur de la fête avec l'aide de bénévoles
appartenant catégorie populaire donc on
voit que historiquement il y avait une
alliance entre les catégories populaires
qui s'entendaient relativement bien avec
les agriculteurs c'était voilà un public
qui vivait dans une certaine osmose et
il tenait un stand de vin chaud sur le
champ de la foire agricole et organiser
un repas campagnard ainsi que divers
animations des noces folkloriques marché
fermier et ainsi de suite toutes ces
sociabilités ont été remises en cause au
cours des années 2000 par les salariés
des classes moyennes et supérieurs
proches du maire socialiste ayant
remporté les élections municipales de
1995-195 donc là il y a vraiment un
bouleversement où il y a une prise de
pouvoir qui est à la fois politique mais
aussi
social par cette festivité vous voyez
avec des activités très
quotidiennes très quotidienne très je
veux dire très banal comme un stand de
vin chaud mais ça va être contesté
jusqu'à ce point là quoi c'est ça qui
est dingue c'est des choses qui sont
tout à fait qui ne peuvent nous
apparaître comme tout à fait futile mais
c'est en fait des objets qui vont être
investis d'une symbolique qui fait que
ça devient déterminant pour
la prédominance dans le village entre
différentes factions
la focale sera resserrée sur les
trajectoires des responsables de la
foire qui ont contesté les positions des
pouvoirs des agriculteurs avant de les
exclure du comité à la fin des années
une appréhension fine est relationnelle
des trajectoires et des positions
sociales des responsables du comité fait
au contraire apparaître des distances
sociales et culturelles à la gare de la
petite bourgeoisie intellectuelle ainsi
qu'une pluralité de parcours résidentiel
marquée par une importante accumulation
de ressources d'autochtonie alors il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sont dites là
mais j'ai passé toute une partie de
l'article mais j'ai repris cette ce
passage là parce que on nous dit que
c'est pas juste une question des
néo-ruraux qui vont évincer les anciens
ruraux si tu veux c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça et il y a des individus
qui reviennent dans le terroir il y a
des individus qui sont nouveaux dans le
terroir
et c'est pas forcément non plus que une
question de de jambes en bas contre des
gens d'en haut tu vois c'est pas c'est
ce genre de fracture qui est ici en
place et on nous parle de l'accumulation
des ressources d'autochtonie et c'est
très intéressant parce que j'ai
découvert en fait qui avait pas mal de
recherches qui travaillaient sur ce
capital culturel particulier qui est
propre au milieu ruraux qui est le fait
tu vois de se sentir du cru d'être
quelqu'un qui appartient au terroir avec
ceux qui n'appartiennent pas et donc il
y a tout un enjeu même pour des nouveaux
arrivants d'essayer d'augmenter leur
capital d'autochtonie parce que ce qui
marche dans un milieu rural ou dans un
espace périurbain anciennement rural
c'est de détenir justement ce capital
d'autochtonie c'est comme du capital
culturel dans le monde scolaire
l'élève qui maîtrise déjà beaucoup de
choses en termes de contenu ou de
langage va avoir une position beaucoup
beaucoup plus valorisés que quelqu'un
qui n'a rien par rapport à ça bien dans
le monde rural c'est ce capital de
tectonie ses ressources de doctonie qui
vont jouer un rôle important
plutôt qu'une opposition entre marginaux
et établi le conflit autour de la foire
mais aux prises des alliances et des
réseaux politiques différenciés composés
de personnes qui occupent toutes des
positions centrales au sein de l'espace
d'interconnaissance et on voit ici que
le capital social est très important
aussi alors j'utilise ces mots de
capital culturel capital social c'est
moi qui l'ai qui les rajoute dans la
lecture pour faire des liens avec des
lectures précédentes ou des théories
bien connues mais ici on est vraiment
comme une sorte de toile d'araignée dans
lequel plus tu vas être au centre du
dispositif ou plutôt tu as des relations
au plus tu pourras tirer ton épingle du
jeu et tu seras bien vu socialement tu
auras donc là plein de capitales
symboliques tu seras quelqu'un
d'apprécier et c'est un peu ce qu'on
cherche tous dans nos différentes
activités c'est d'être apprécié pour ce
que l'on fait ou ce que l'on est
et donc après il y a tout un paragraphe
qui nous explique la méthodologie cet
article repose sur une enquête de
terrain menée à plibout entre 2014 et
2017 donc on voit que l'enquête a duré 3
ans peut-être pas de manière continue on
y a une note un frapaginal qui nous
renvoie vers un autre article de Quentin
schnappeur qui nous permet de le
découvrir ça sera peut-être l'occasion
de faire une prochaine lecture si ce
thème intéresse mais pour vous dire
aussi que l'article date de 2022 et donc
il y a eu 5 ans depuis l'arrêt de
l'observation pour vous dire que le
temps de la recherche n'est pas le temps
de l'actualité ou des journaux quoi
il faut un certain temps pour pouvoir
travailler analyser publié quand on
travaille de manière rigoureuse et
scientifique
il mobilise plus précisément des
matériaux collectés en 2014 et 2015 dans
le cadre d'un suivi des activités du
comité d'organisation de la Foire
d'Automne j'ai assisté à une douzaine de
réunions du COFA et participer au
sociabilité amicales de ce de ses
responsables donc là il y a une
observation immersive qui s'est faite
une observation participante comme on le
dirait ou Quentin a vraiment intégré le
tissu local et quand il dit il faut lire
entre les lignes mais quand il dit j'ai
participé pardon je suis donc j'ai suivi
les activités d'organisations de la
Foire d'Automne j'assistais à une
douzaine de réunions du COFA et
participer au sociabilité amical de ses
responsables ça veut dire que il a été
boire un verre avec eux et qu'ils ont
peut-être fait
guindaï ensemble ils ont bu quelques
verres ensemble en fin de soirée et donc
il a dû participer donner de sa personne
si vous me comprenez pour
réaliser l'enquête il y a aussi à côté
de ça 35 entretiens ce sont des échanges
beaucoup plus
interpersonnelles et formalisé ont
également été conduits avec les
différents protagonistes de la
manifestation et des élus du conseil
municipal j'ai bénéficié d'une double
entrée sur ce terrain du côté des
agriculteurs je suis très proche de
Louis chabiran trésorier de
l'association et ancien conseil
municipal le plus beau durant 25 ans
dont la fille m'a gardé durant mon
enfance passer à une vingtaine de
kilomètres du bourg donc ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ici on se rend
compte qu'en fait c'est son c'est son
village plus ou moins natal
du côté des autres membres du COFA j'ai
bénéficié de la pluie de Claude ribro
ancien facteur inscrit dans le réseau de
l'Amicale laïque qui m'a fait entrer au
sein du comité cette double affiliation
m'a permis d'éviter les effets dans
cliquage donc là ça renvoie un autre
article si on voulait savoir ce qu'est
ce que sont les effets d'anticash on
pourrait aller le voir et de circuler
sans trop de difficultés entre ces deux
groupes en conflit on reviendra dans un
premier temps sur les recompositions des
sociabilités politiques dans le bourg à
la fin des années 70 et la contestation
du conseil municipal sans étiquette le
renversement de la majorité en 1995-95
c'est clair le renouvellement du COFA et
les enjeux qui sous tendent l'éviction
et la démobilisation des agriculteurs et
de leurs alliés dans les années 2010 la
troisième partie explore enfin
l'entre-soi des responsables du comité
et la manière dont il rend possible un
engagement distancié dans les
sociabilités populaires de la foire bon
on pourrait se poser quand même une
question en la méthodologique étant
donné qu'il est très proche de certains
acteurs de par son enfance
est-ce que est-ce que l'analyse est
vraiment extérieure donc là ça serait
intéressant de rencontrer quand un
sniper pour savoir comment il a vécu ça
et comment est-ce qu'il a mis en
distance à distance son objet pour ne
pas justement être trois influencé par
son sa propre histoire
alors je ne vais bien sûr pas lire ici
tout l'article je vais vous lire
quelques petits éléments parce que pour
moi l'essentiel est dit c'est toute la
construction de cet objet et vous
montrer que à partir d'une fête de
village d'une foire je sais pas une
foire au boudin d'un barbecue d'un bar à
vin chaud d'un stand de vin chaud et
bien il y a déjà des constructions qu'on
peut faire pour obtenir un objet d'étude
alors en 2014 2015 les 16 membres du
COFA hors collège agricole sont en
majorité des hommes d'une cinquantaine
d'années appartenant au classe moyenne
ou supérieur des secteurs publics et
paraps publics cadres dans les
assurances agents commerciales SNCF
facteurs contre le travail
donc là c'est pour vous donner un peu la
sociologie des groupes en conflit au
sein de l'association les comptes-rendus
des réunions déplorent également depuis
la fin des années 90-90 le manque de
jeûne pour monter dans les stands de
lors de la Foire d'Automne donc là on
constate que les agriculteurs de
l'époque qui étaient les chevilles
ouvrières de ce comité bien finalement
voyez déjà la fin avenir par le non
renouvellement de leurs effectifs dans
un contexte de fortes résorption du
nombre d'exploitants dans le bourg les
agriculteurs ont dû se résoudre à faire
appel à la bénévole de la paroisse
appartenant au classe moyenne garagiste
kinésithérapeute enseignant du privé et
là on explique cette sorte d'alliance
qui est faite entre les classes
populaires et les agriculteurs
et ont élargi le recrutement de leur
association vers des ouvriers des
employés à retraite proche des milieux
agricoles ces catégories populaires
forment désormais le principal public de
leur animation repas d'ensemble échoui
excursion et donc quel est le public de
toutes ces activités il est
principalement populaire et donc là on
se pose aussi à la question mais que
viennent faire les classes supérieures
dans ces activités qu'elle n'aime pas
objectivement en tant que tel et on le
verra plus tard une grande partie de ces
personnes alliées aux agriculteurs sont
arrivés à pliboux dans les années
70-80 jusqu'en 2015 les réunions du
comité d'organisation de la foire sont
marqués par l'opposition entre d'un côté
5 agriculteurs de l'association et de
l'autre les membres du cofac qui les
surnomme les vieux ou les paysans vous
voyez une sorte de dédain aussi qui est
mise en place
les agriculteurs arrivent avec une seule
voiture ça soit toujours ensemble dans
un coin de la pièce et ne participe
pratiquement pas aux discussions après
avoir bu un verre par politesse à la fin
de la réunion ils partent les premiers
en ouvrant alors la salle des critiques
et des moqueries imitant leur intonation
en patois donc ceux qui restent donc
c'est à dire que les cadres
supérieurs ou des classes moyennes qui
font partie du comité bon soute de leur
gueule dès qu'ils sont partis quoi en
justement en ciblant un petit peu ce qui
fait leur appartenance au terroir les
intonations abattois en patois c'est de
ça qu'on va se moquer les points de
tension sont multiples les responsables
du coffret revendiquent d'abord un
rapport plus entrepreneurial à la foire
donc eux voilà on va faire du business
en fait on va gérer les choses comme on
les gérer dans nos activités
professionnelles
cela consiste à chercher en permanence à
innover et à prendre des risques tout ça
est mis entre guillemets parce que c'est
des mots qui ont important ils dévoilent
toute une représentation du monde aussi
pour améliorer les spectacles ou les
lots de tombola donc voilà on voit la
tombe là d'une manière un peu plus
gestionnaire ou entrepreneuriale avec
leur habitude finalement leur
comportement leur logique de leur vie
professionnelle qui va simplement être
transposé dans leur vie ici associative
à l'image de l'invariable repent repas
jambon moguette mogette pardon les
paysans c'est toujours la même chose
distille la reconduction à l'identique
des animations des agriculteurs est
perçue comme autant de signes de leur
passéisme de leur incapacité à se
renouveler les autres ils sont dépassés
du style faut-il faut faire des foires
de demain pas des foires d'il y a 30 ans
soulignent Didier aubino directeur de
filiale commerciale de l'usine de
camping-car de leur côté les
agriculteurs dénoncent la folie des
grandeurs des membres du COFA et
revendique la réservation de l'ambiance
agricole de la Foire des années 1950 de
1960 ouais c'est l'opposition qui se
fait dans cette foire entre deux mondes
l'opposition entre les deux groupes
s'inscrit dans l'espace à travers la
juxtaposition de leurs animations les
agriculteurs se trouvent en plein air
sur le champ de foire le cœur historique
de la manifestation ou s'échanger les
bestiaux jusque dans les années 1980
c'est là qu'il tienne le stand de vin
chaud et leur marché fermier tandis que
les responsables du COFA occupent
principalement les anciennes halles
situées juste au dessus avec des
expositions à thème et une buvette
concurrente même l'espace voilà est mis
en tension et mis en concurrence la
contestation des positions de pouvoir
des agriculteurs c'est accompagné chez
eux d'un processus de rigidification et
de monopolisation des appartenances
locales selon une logique binaire
étrangers autochtones eux les
agriculteurs sont les vrais tandis que
les autres voilà ce sont des étrangers
ceux du COFA il y en a pas un qui est
natif de plibou
une manière de dénier aux autres membres
du comité tout droit
sur la foire et de son histoire vous
voyez c'est vraiment la légitimité qui
est mise en cause d'un côté on dit ben
voilà c'est c'est des gens qui sont
dépassés qui sont plus dans le monde
dans lequel on est et des gens pas
séistes et de l'autre on dit mais c'est
pas des gens d'ici quoi
le conflit est enfin d'ordre pécuniaire
gardant pour une partie des bénéfices du
stand de vin chaud pour financer les
activités de leur association les
agriculteurs sont accusés d'égoïsme ils
font quand même la foire sur notre dos
et puis on attend deux et c'est pour se
promener c'est pour faire des
méchouilles ça emporte un soir Régine
Soulis qui est une membre du Coffin
les membres du Coface se place en
contrepoint
du côté de l'intérêt général et
revendique une fête qui profite à
l'ensemble de la population du bourg
c'est de la même manière un problème
d'argent qui précipite l'évictions des
agriculteurs la fin de l'année 2015 ces
derniers ont refusé de rétrocéder au
comité une subvention qui leur avait été
octroyé avant de se retirer de la foire
6 semaines avant l'événement la décision
est alors prise de les exclure pour
faute grave voilà
bon je vais je vais vraiment pas tout
lire je vous invite à vous procurer cet
article si ça vous intéresse
je vais lire quelques passages parce que
c'est assez intéressant
mais voilà je passe vraiment sous
silence toutes des nuances et beaucoup
de choses de l'article il faut le savoir
quoi c'est pas une lecture parfaite et
fidèle de l'article je fais ici c'est
vraiment une présentation une sélection
alors sous le titre organisé une fête
populaire en petits comité on nous dit
que viennent faire les cadres et les
professions intermédiaires du COFA dans
cette fête du village parce que voilà à
la base ils aiment pas trop ça leur
implication dans la foire renvoie
d'abord au souci de préserver
l'animation et une image rurale et
villageoise du bourg dans le cadre de
pratique festive qui alimente des jeux
de distinction pourquoi est-ce qu'ils se
font ça mais c'est pour se distinguer
vis-à-vis de la petite bourgeoisie
culturelle locale on a la petite
bourgeoisie culturelle locale je sais
pas peut-être un médecin peut-être qu'il
est eux ne vont pas se mêler au fait
populaire à la vie festive de plibout
qui sont un petit peu en retraite tout
ça et puis on a les nouveaux arrivants
qui eux veut montrer que ils ont une
volonté à l'authenticité qu'ils ont une
volonté de faire vivre la ruralité du
village et donc eux vont s'investir donc
en fait vous voyez c'est plus qu'un jeu
simplement d'opposition il y a un jeu de
distinction au sein même de la
bourgeoisie entre la bourgeoisie
d'origine et la bourgeoisie importée ou
réimportée je sais pas comment il
faudrait le dire qui elle va essayer de
montrer qu'elle est mieux que la
bourgeoisie locale parce que elle voilà
elle veut participer à la vie du village
les c'est exactement des trucs que je
peux observer dans mon village à moi ce
genre de choses les responsables du
comité cherchent à ainsi à organiser une
manifestation accessible au plus grand
nombre tout en réaffirmant les
frontières d'un entre soi de classe
moyenne et supérieure qui rend possible
un investissement distancié dans ces
sociabilités populaires
la bibliothèque c'est plus intello la
fête contre la culture donc c'est
vraiment cette opposition entre la
bourgeoisie locale qui est plus attachée
à la culture à la bibliothèque locale et
cette bourgeoisie
qui arrive qui veut prendre le pouvoir
et qui elle va réinvestir la fête mais
pour des logiques distinctives le COFA
forme un petit cercle de sociabilité
masculine dont les soirées se prolonge
souvent jusqu'au petit matin l'alcool
est dent ces nuits se passent à refaire
le monde au cours d'interminables
discussions où se mêlent des jeux à
boire des défis potages et d'autres
formes de relâchement donc tout ça ce
sont les cadres supérieurs finalement
qui vont se lâcher dans ces sociabilité
nouvelles
jouer du ACDC ac/dc à fond en air
guitare jusqu'à casser une enceinte
urinée dans le jardin public depuis le
premier étage de la salle polyvalente
jouer au bottle flip challenge les
épouses des responsables du comité leur
envoient régulièrement des messages pour
leur demander de rentrer sont souvent
contraintes de jouer les chauffeurs
lorsqu'ils ont trop bu ces anecdotes
sont ensuite partagées et commentées au
cours des réunions comme autant de faits
d'armes qui marquent l'appartenance au
sociabilité du comité c'est pratique
festives fondées sur une division des
sexes relativement rigides ne sont pas
la panache des catégories populaires
elle concerne dans ce cas des salariés
de classe moyenne et supérieurs qui
occupent des positions d'honorabilité à
l'échelle locale conseiller municipaux
responsable du comité des fêtes ou
d'associations locales à l'image du
karaoké chez les cadres du privé et là
on renvoie sur un autre article qui nous
parle voilà d'une pratique qui n'est pas
du tout légitime au sein de classe
sociale qui normalement consomme des des
productions ou des comportements où on
des comportements très légitimes c'est
sociabilité renvoie des conduites de
relâchement et de défoulement marquer
par la distance à la culture légitime et
le souci de ne pas se prendre au sérieux
et bien voilà article très intéressant
il y aura encore beaucoup de choses à
lire mais je pense qu'il y aura aussi
un stream sur twitch qui sera beaucoup
plus long que celui-ci dans lequel je
reviendrai sur d'autres éléments il y a
un élément que je ne vous lirai pas
aujourd'hui mais j'aurais voulu vous en
parler c'est le fait que à certains
moments de l'article c'est cadre
supérieur ou
issu des classes moyennes en fait n'aime
pas trop ces activités et donc ils y
vont un petit peu Hercule long et ils
ont toujours le mot pour un peu
critiquer même s'ils participent en
disant voilà je participe
à l'activité mais bon voilà et donc ils
vont relativiser ils y croient pas c'est
pas capital pour eux ils y croient pas
tant que ça quand ils y participent
contrairement aux publics plus
populaires ou des agriculteurs
voilà bien je vous remercie pour votre
attention et je vous donne rendez-vous
pour une prochaine lecture de sciences
sociales sur la société à très